alexander skarsgard looks totally ripped
in the northmen but how exactly did he
make himself look like some kind of
monster to quote a co-star keep watching
to find out the northmen stars alexander
skarsgard as amleth a former prince who
returns home after many years to exact
revenge for the murder of his father the
king played by ethan hawk and the
kidnapping of his mother the queen
played by nicole kidman amleth who was
raised by a band of vikings after
narrowly escaping a similar fate embarks
on a brutal journey to confront his
murderous uncle the robert egger's
viking epic which will land in theaters
on april 22 has received strong praise
from critics many of whom have noted the
ferocity of skarsgard's acting indeed
the film's leading man is a sight to
behold navigating an ancient world of
mysticism and violence with seemingly
unlimited stamina skarsgard has
mentioned how grueling an ordeal it was
to shoot the northmen but it's clear
that all the hard work paid off as
amleth the actor is a ferocious wall of
muscle making every bit of struggle and
bloody combat feel believable his
co-star ralph eineson told nme that the
transformation was stunning and compared
him to a bodybuilder he's made himself
look like some kind of monster for the
part the dedication's incredible i think
it will be a bit of a masterpiece to be
honest so how did skarsgard go from lean
to mean and shredded his personal
trainer for the northmen explained the
process and it sounds like a lot thanks
to a report by collider we've got an
in-depth look at how trainer magnus
ligbach got alexander skarsgard in shape
for the northmen it sounds as though
ligbach followed a classic regimen with
some of his own wisdom and preferences
mixed in first was the bulking period
during which skarsgard ate lots of food
to build as much muscle mass as possible
after that came cutting which saw
skarsgard training to keep the newly
gained muscle while shredding excess fat
this is one area where it sounds like
lidbach made some changes to accommodate
skarsgard's specific needs for the
northmen as the trainer explained
normally i do 8 to 10 weeks but we
didn't want alex to be too shredded he
shredded enough right and we wanted him
to look a little thicker and finally
like bach worked with the actor to keep
his body in peak physical performance
throughout the movie to avoid the
possibility of injuries while filming
the action heavy sequences while movie
star training programs are often
associated with mounds of unseasoned
chicken or other such bulking foods like
box says training for the northmen
allowed skarsgard to eat more or less
what he wanted as he put it we allowed
alex to have a glass of wine on
saturdays and eat food that he likes to
eat however that doesn't mean the food
was unimportant ligbach instructed
skarsgard to eat 5 meals per day and he
also personally designed skarsgard's
menus making sure the actor finished his
plate bligbach joked if that means you
need to stand over and tell him to
finish that's what's gonna happen
alexander skarsgard's hardcore
transformation for the northmen wasn't
the first time he's trained with magnus
ligbach the celebrity trainer also
helped the actor prepare for his leading
role in the 2016 film the legend of
tarzan to play tarzan skarsgard
underwent movement practice and a
four-month training regimen in which he
gained 25 pounds i thought that it would
be a dream but it was tough because i
had to get up at three in the morning
and eat a cold steak and potatoes and
stuff like bach who's known for creating
jaw-dropping results with his clients
admitted that he was shocked by
skarsgard's dedication he told men's
journal i've never seen anyone more hard
working i had to force him to take days
off sometimes he was eating food out of
a box for about eight months and not a
drop of alcohol like the regimen for the
northmen this fitness journey involved a
strict diet and a focus on weightlifting
given their success together it's no
surprise that they teamed up again for
the viking film wigbach told gq that he
enjoys working with skarsgard who
responds well to their training and
shows a fierce dedication to the work he
told the magazine you know working with
alex is just you know what you're
getting you get someone who's talented
hard working and has the genetics
ligbach went on to say that despite the
stunning results skarsgard isn't
naturally a gym rat but his client's
love of running was beneficial to their
training check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one